Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Now when you guys watch MMA and you see someone like Stephen Thompson that has
very,
a few elements of Moitai he uses,
but he uses a lot of sport karate,
which is a,
you know,
a completely different stance,
a completely different style.
What's your take on that when you watch that or what his style or when they,
this style is Moitai well,
they definitely don't really,
I mean,
well leg kicks and some techniques,
but essentially he's doing a sport karate style.
Well,
it was,
it was kind of the same thing with Anderson Silva.
It's like just cause someone's throwing an elbow,
just because somebody has a clinch doesn't necessarily make it [inaudible].
There's a lot of arts that have those things.
You know what I mean?
And I'm not going to view him as a Muay Thai fight.
I think of Anderson is a motif.
I am not at all.
He thought of himself as a [inaudible].
Well that's okay,
but,
but I wouldn't view him as of when we tie fighter at all.
I knew him as an MMA.
Anything he did was very moist.
Even his clinch was,
I mean,
that's such a fundamental,
basic clinch,
you know what I mean?
That's just because everyone else was so terrible at it.
It's like grab the neck,
like you don't see that in high level Muay Thai guys going up and grabbing each
other by the neck.
It's in transition and one of the hurt people when they get tired very,
it's very much a,
um,
us of struggling for dominance over under those kinds of things like big,
sloppy,
ridiculous.
Armbar yeah,
dude.
I mean like,
like it's like,
that's like day one more time.
So when you saw that like the rich Franklin fight
in the fuck,
like how did he not learn this as first day in training and what was even worse
was,
um,
I had a friend that I trained with that went out to help him for the second one
and he just didn't want to hear it.
Like they did not want to hear that.
Like,
dude,
you don't know what you're doing at all.
Because as well we talked about earlier,
these guys get to a high level and think that they're,
um,
maybe we'll tie you technique is good.
And I'm like,
dude,
you are like a kindergartener.
Like you don't know what you're doing at all whatsoever.
He didn't want to listen,
so.
Wow,
that's crazy.
That look,
so w who was it that went out with him?
Uh,
Anthony Brown,
all the trading partner of mine.
And he was specifically brought there because of his Moitai.
Yeah,
without a doubt.
I'm like,
why would you,
why would you bring me in if you're not going to use me?
I mean,
I've been brought in for people to,
and why wouldn't you use what you've brought me in here to do?
You know what I mean?
Like you brought me in for my Muay Thai for my knowledge in this thing.
And you just want to keep doing what you're good at.
Like,
why am I here?
This is stupid.
That's unfortunate.
He's such a nice guy and such a smart guy.
He was a math teacher without a doubt.
How do you not see the math of that?
It's when people aren't,
people have a false sense of where they're at in the sport and what they can do.
And I'm like,
you literally know nothing,
but you have this mentality that you're,
you're decent at standup,
you're decent,
Emma.
We tie and you're terrible compared to someone that really does know what
they're doing.
You know what I mean?
Most people's understanding is very elementary.
If that,
you know,
you take another person and I'm going to,
I could beat you without even like touching you.
You know what I mean?
Just,
and just to let you mess yourself up because you don't really know what you're
doing.
It's a,
it's crazy to think that someone could reach the world championship level and
something that involves more Moitai,
but there's so many variables that come be,
there's wrestling,
there's two shits is,
there's always things.
There's,
you can get away with a lot more like the striking and MMA you can get away with
because of those variables,
because of the smaller gloves,
because of the take downs,
you know,
you put that person in the ring with even a moderately good muay Thai person,
moderately good boxer,
they're going to get murdered.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Right,
right.
Just like it can bring in like a really good point that I fire him but then
don't have any wrestling,
different defense or no digits.
They're not going to do it.
Be able to do.
Exactly.
Look like an idiot.
Well that's one of the appeals of MMA.
Yeah.
Is that the guy who wins is most likely the best fighter because if it was just
more tie or if it was just wrestling or if it was just Jujitsu,
you would see someone who's the best at that.
But when you throw everything in,
like it's the kitchen sink,
get in there and that's when you know,
you get to see like who's been,
I mean it was even more complex puzzle.
Yeah.
That's why like I,
I've never really understood the argument of like pitting this person against
that person or like who's got the best when we tighten them,
mate,
we'll nobody,
cause they're not doing Muay Thai,
right.
That,
that argument,
that conversation is completely invalid.
Like,
Oh,
if you put this boxer and against this Muay Thai fighter,
who's going to win?
I don't know what rules are they fighting under their fighting under mood.
Tyrell's east probably going to get crushed.
You know what I mean?
Well,
it's interesting that a Wonderboy Thompson is going to fight Tyron Woodley,
who's the UFC welterweight champion and who's just super powerful wrestler,
but who's also training with Duke Roufus who's obviously very talented,
knows a lot about Moitai great coach.
Um,
what,
when you see a guy like that?
Well,
the reason why I keep bringing up,
um,
Wonderboy styles because it's so unique.
You know,
we brought up Raymond Daniels in glory who is one of the only guys that has like
that similar background.
And then Michael Page of course,
in MMA who fights for belt or has a very similar style to that sport karate
style.
What are the holes in that style?
Like what's,
what's the pros and cons that you see as a fighter?
What we were speaking of earlier,
it's,
if you've never applied that in a fight,
a real fight,
not,
not point sparring,
not that,
that kind of thing.
There's certain techniques and things that are completely worthless.
And unfortunately in a lot of those sports you are not,
you don't get exposed by that until it's way too late.
So you're trying these techniques that,
you know,
a,
a decent person just kind of walk right through because they look good and
they're flashing and they're great on the pads and,
and,
and all that.
But,
but when you have to damage someone,
obviously Thomson knows how to do that though.
And it's using techniques and,
but,
but applying them in a,
in a more fight,
uh,
centric way and it's completely different thing.
But when you see what I was trying to get at,
is that such a weird style where you stand sideways and he leaps in and out and
he moves back and forth from the waist,
like a snake.
I mean,
he's got a lot of it.
There's a lot of weirdness to the way he moves and it's very difficult to find
anybody that has that level skill with a sport,
karate,
kickboxing,
but also has a really good wrestling base to,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I think that's one of the biggest things and why he's able to apply those
things because,
because he can deal with the wrestling and everything else that goes in,
so,
so that's why you'll see him throw those techniques because he's not as worried
about it as someone who might be just as good as him with those things in,
and it has zero ground or wrestling where they're not going to throw it because
they're going to get taken down.
Crushed.
Yeah.
It's like we were talking about your experience in a taekwondo school that you
went there the first day,
start doing sparring you through a low kick,
and then like get outta here.
Tons of go.
So you'd do it.
Something to do effective.
Yeah.
So being able to apply things in a real fight and being able to apply them in
the air is,
is very different.
Right.
Obviously we see Thompson can apply them in a real fight.
What is he doing that you see that's different?
Like,
I mean obviously it's not a Moy Thai fighter,
he's a kickboxer,
but like when you see that stance,
that weird stance,
that sideways stance,
what do you think about that?
Oh,
I don't think much about it cause I don't watch a lot of MMA,
you know?
I mean I do a little bit better.
I don't,
I wouldn't say I follow it,
you know what I mean?
I watch it when it's on,
but I'm not the,
you know,
like paying attention to the fighters are tracking them throughout the years.
You know that much.
I'm just so curious because you are so Moitai you know your style,
so more tie in.
You're obviously an expert at it.
I'm always curious as to like how a person,
like you observes a,
an expert striker in sort of another realm.
Well,
I think he's an expert and he's become an expert striker and MMA.
So he's applying all the techniques that he know him.
He knows him.
Ha Ha have worked for him and MMA.
So it's different than if he would get in the ring and do Moitai.
Yeah.
How many fighters like him have done Moitai.
Obviously Raymond Daniels has done kickboxing and some you know and it,
but it's another one of those things where being able to apply the things from
your other sport into that.
So like we were talking about with the Raymond Daniels and Nikki Holt skin,
like he just walked him down.
He was like Bop,
bop crushing the legs.
Tylene too.
So at a certain level it Kinda,
you'll lose that like where you're,
you're spinning flashy techniques are going to work against,
you know,
those,
those mid level guys.
But you put them in there with the best in the world and a lot of that stuff
gets exposed in is not working out so well.
And you think that essentially demonstrates the effectiveness of Moitai at the
highest levels.
You think it's the best demonstrates the,
the holes.
And some of the stances in techniques.
Um,
if I'm not flinching on the things you do and don't really care so much about
you hopping around and spin around,
I'm just walking you down,
crushing you.
Um,
you know that that's where that kind of gets exposed.
So it's like,
it's like putting a boxer into a Muay Thai fight I'm going to do is kick your
legs and you can't punch me.
Right.
You know what I mean?
But you take a boxer and teach them how to defend though those kicks and Stan
and a little bit more of a squared up way and where I can't use you use your
weakness against you as much.
You're going to have much better success even if you've never throw quick.
Now you just can take those kicks better and just kill me with your,
your high level hands.
Okay.